foreign
does to replace tasks there are tasks
that we do most jobs are complex of
different tasks a lot of these tasks
will go to the AI but not necessarily
the job okay so the job will shift and
you'll have different tasks
part of that strength is that I would
actually maybe even expand this even
broader and people in a welcome feedback
on this my claim would be that I don't
think there's anybody in any field
that's lost their job because of AI so
far
um
there's tasks that have gone away but
not jobs and
a lot of the worry about this AI is what
I call third person worry
they're saying my job hobby I'm not
going to be replaced but I can imagine
some somebody else or maybe I can
imagine my friend losing it but but I'm
still waiting for someone to say I lost
my job a real person with a real name
who lost their job because of AI and so
far
I haven't I've maybe even offer like a
200 Bounty if you tell me the name
specific person who lost her job because
of AI of any sort
and it's because yeah why take such a
binary
bet I know you like these guys I would
take the opposite side of that but
please continue well you could take it
by giving a name I just have to fire
somebody
no you but you're at the AI so I'm
saying because of AI well I would have
to replace them with AI and then I can
blame it on that right okay and you
won't be able to do that right now okay
let's take an example if I may yes logo
design yes that is what somebody does
day in day out right they design logo
right and I have gone to some of the
local designers AI local there are logo
AI designers right now and they're
amazing
but here's the position and this is my
position is what we get from these AIS
currently right now are Universal
personal interns or intern they're doing
the work of interns UPS upis okay and
they're really amazing
but you have to check their work
it's embarrassing to release
their work
without Improvement the intern work yeah
so I've used these logo AI generators
and I'll work with them over and over
again and this is what the artist will
be doing the artist is going to be
working with their interns generating
all these possibilities tweaking them
they're kind of like a director or
conductor they're managing the interns
and they're not releasing the intern
work
unedited unpolished uncurated
and that's what their new tasks become
the artists
I'm not totally convinced however I
think that will happen but I I do thank
some Rank and file will perhaps need to
find new jobs at the very least if
someone has AI
as the UPI I would imagine if you have a
brand Design Studio that focuses on
logos with 30 employees some of which
are junior there might be some Shuffle
but we can go ahead I mean there's going
to be a lot of art generated from these
entities these AIS and I always want to
say plural always plural there's not one
AI there's AIS all different species
but most of that work is being used for
areas that are blank now where there is
no pictures where there isn't anything
so I have
my assistant actually has for years
woke up in the middle of night to write
her dreams down
and now she feeds those dreams into the
air and she illustrates them and they're
just amazing there were no illustrations
before now they're illustrations yep I
use them to generate images for my
slides there were no pictures before now
there are pictures so it's not like I'm
replacing somebody it's not a zero
filling it in yeah and by the way
there's about 30 million
brand new never seen before images
generated every day
with these image generators 30 million
and I would say about maybe 95 or maybe
98 of them there's an audience of one
it's for the pure pleasure
of seeing this it's like it's like you
would take a walk out into the into
nature and just see a a beautiful scene
it's like I'm just enjoying this this is
why they're mostly being generated yeah
the predominant number of them just
because they're beautiful
okay and so they weren't there before
that you could not have your own private
Museum of these really cool images maybe
no one will ever see again yeah okay and
so
that's what they're being mostly used
for is filling in the blank spaces and
that's also true again of a lot of the
other intern work that may be writing
things that nobody else but the boss
sees yeah
let's look at this a little more closely
so
I will say just as a means of setting
the table I'm deeply deeply interested
in these tools which is why and the
effects that they will have on
the creative economies the economy
period broadly speaking Society
I think they're very underestimated
and I'd love to get your take on that in
a bit
I've run AI art competitions related to
some of the fiction that I put out and
have been absolutely Blown Away
I also
sympathize with some artists say on
artstation or deviantART who are part of
the training set who are popularly
mimicked right so
prompt
yada yada in the style of fill in the
blank
and I can understand why these artists
would be upset feel threatened maybe be
financially impacted I imagine their
commissioned work might be
how do you think that'll shake out and I
know based on some of the conversations
that we've had that
I believe your perspective is if if
people are relevant they're going to be
copied anyway right and if they're not
it doesn't really matter if they're in
the training data right something along
those lines
so Picasso's influence is going to be
seen all over the place no matter what
but how do you think this will shake out
in the next handful of years because I
understand why people would have an
aversion as artists
I think there will be
people
companies who make training sets they're
all opt-in in some capacity maybe most
of it's sort of you know already out of
copyright
and they'll be sold as green watches
ethical you know training sets whatever
it is fair trade AI artwork exactly and
there could be a lot of them where
people will use it they'll train the
things on their own work
like help me make more images in my
style I am doing some experience with
that right now exactly and there's going
to be this ability over time to require
less of a training set for right now we
can only way we train these is the more
the billions the better but
human toddler can learn
the difference between a cat and a dog
just with 12 examples and when we start
to have more targeted like that I think
people will start to clamor to be
included in the training set what needs
to happen for the AIS to require far
fewer examples in these these training
data sets we don't know
that's the short answer but we suspect
it's an existence proof because we have
time so many but it may require right
now there's kind of the Brute Force
these neural Nets brute first meaning
that they're very flat and they didn't
work in the beginning because they
weren't big enough and the bigger we
make them
they seem to overcome a lot of the
problems
but it's really clear to most people
that we can't get all the way to where
we want to go
just with these flat because these
models basically they do one and a half
things they do pattern recognition in
pattern generation that's all they don't
do symbolic logic inductive reasoning
the current ones aren't capable of that
ironing tough irony and so it's just
amazing that they have gone as far as
they have and we keep expecting that
they can't go any further but they keep
surprising us but we're pretty sure that
they can't go all the way and the
example I would use is like Wikipedia
Wikipedia is a flat the idea was the
flat that comes up from the bottom if
it's bottom up
it's like how far can you make it
reliable encyclopedia just from the
bottom up well a lot farther than you
initially thought but we also know that
Wikipedia has succeeded because in
recent years have been more top-down
control of the editors and you have to
have for ultimately what you want a
combination of mostly bottom up that's
somewhat regulated by some top-down
control editorial control all that kind
of stuff and that's what we don't really
have in AI right now we have just the
bottom up
it's very very bottom up and there's
just the suspicion looking at kind of
the Santa Fe work on complex adaptive
systems that you go one to have some
top-down governance to assist
this bottom up to get where you want to
go